of course we are concerned that that's
for sure and and that is the situation
we see that the situation from the uh
when they start sharing from the fifth
of august it's changed dramatically and
of course we are concerned that's why we
are here that's why we created uh this
group that's why we are involved in
everyday communication with this and we
speak to our international partners also
that of course we are concerned
we want to see impartiality we want to
see
that the eia should say something
about the war they should say something
about nuclear safety because you cannot
just close the eyes and say that that if
you see the military there if you see
the weapon and of course it's influenced
it's directly influenced the the safety
of nuclear material at this station
and and that that that's what we want to
see and of course we understand that
from the other hand uh they they need to
give some some technical estimation on
what is happening because we we just
have uh not not concrete information
what is inside there
that was
you